okay so
what i will do today and maybe before i
share my screen actually i will go to
the program page where you can kind of
see
that we structured this program around
the q and a sessions
the first part of the program is going
to cover the introduction to the basic
skills that you must have to work with
genomic data that will include a brief
overview that we will do today
of all the tools and different aspects
that you can learn about
then you can practice independently how
to do these things on your own and make
sure that you know how to do this
independently and then we will have a q
a session on february 21st
and when we do that q a session we are
looking for your questions what are some
of the things that you didn't understand
what are some of the things that you
want more clarity on what are some of
the additional topics that we didn't
cover so that we can make sure that
those are clearly outlined in this live
q a session
and also by the way during today's
session feel free to post any of your
questions or comments in the chat
that will give us a better understanding
of what we should be covering and how to
address the specific concerns that you
must that you might have
so what i will do today is i will give
you a very quick introduction to genomic
data
processing and analysis
then we will do some hands-on exercises
so that you can get a sense of what are
some of the different methods and tools
that we will be using throughout this
program
and then at the end i will kind of go
back to the schedule and some of the
programmatic aspects of this training so
that you are comfortable with uh the
program outcomes what what what is
expected from you uh throughout this
whole program
so the
genomic data analysis program
is designed to introduce you to the
tools
of analyzing dna
code sequences
and making interpretations
based on that
analysis
and to begin speaking about this let's
briefly talk about next generation
sequencing so
dna
was described the structure of dna in
the 1950s and then over the course of
the next several decades this rapid pace
of
technology development led to
cheaper sequences
cheaper sequencing and an abundance of
data that could be analyzed that is used
as a reference that we know kind of
what's happening in different diseases
and in different populations but also
allows us to understand uh different
specific project examples without even
having to do sequencing ourselves so we
can actually take sequencing data from
other labs other research studies and
ask questions about dna variation but
onyx data doesn't just describe dna
omics data could refer to different
types of omics for example phenomics
genomics
epigenomics
transcriptomics even metagenomics right
and so there are many different omics
data types and what we will do in this
program is we will specifically look at
genomic data
in association with these other types of
omics for example how does the genotype
affect the phenotype so how can we
connect the morphology and the way that
tissues and cells function with dna
sequences or transcriptomics how are
those defined by the specific genes that
are expressed or the isoforms that are
being expressed
so one of the things that we would like
to understand
is the relationship between structure
function maybe evolution right how did
we get here and the way we can do this
is by looking at
known sequences for example genes that
have been annotated we can ask questions
about what these genes do or what kind
of variation in the gene sequence
doesn't let them do what they're
designed to do
and then we'll talk about how the next
generation sequencing data that
describes the genomic variation can be
analyzed to identify some of those
changes some of those variants
so essentially what we're looking for is
if we are thinking about the dna code as
a
specific instruction about a protein or
about a gene
we are looking for bugs in the code that
change how that protein or that gene
works
and a good example of that is described
here with the red blood cell you have
the normal red blood cell or you have
the mutant and that leads to disease
that
is a result of a variant
so to understand
where these variants are found and
characterize them we need to know a
little bit about what types of variation
we expect to find
in the dna code
we have nucleotide sequences you will
often hear the terms base pairs or
nucleotides
and those refer to individual
nucleotides on one strand of the dna or
two strands if it's a base pair
and essentially those are organized into
trinucleotide codons
those codons code for amino acids and
amino acids are what the proteins are
made of so when we look at the dna code
we're oftentimes thinking how are these
nucleotide sequences encoding for amino
acid sequences and how do the changes at
the nucleotide level result in either a
different
type of an amino acid or even a stop
codon right that the whole sequence
stops
being
transcribed at all
and so
those are point mutations point
mutations are going to take up the
majority of our time we're going to be
looking at individual
single
varia variants that could either be
categorized as substitutions insertions
or deletions
so we can either expect one nucleotide
to be substituted by another
we can
envision a or we can encounter a
nucleotide being inserted in the
sequence or being deleted from that
sequence and based on where exactly in
that codon sequence this change happened
we will expect very different types of
outcomes
and those will be specific to different
types of applications because
we will look at how
germline mutations somatic mutations or
even
frequency of mutations in specific
positions can have different effects
across different conditions diseases and
phenotypes
so the basic
way to annotate and identify
how this particular change can impact
whatever happens at the phenotypic level
or at the functional level
we can look at single nucleotide changes
and describe them as those that occur in
less or more than one percent of the
population and those that have more than
one percent of the uh
one percent of the population would be
considered uh polymorphisms or snips
single nucleotide polymorphisms
then if they are single nucleotide
polymorphisms we will consider whether
they are in the coding or the non-coding
region
of a gene
and if they are in the coding region we
typically will ask the question
do they change the amino acid or do they
not change the amino acid and if they
don't change
we will still
think that maybe they could be
associated with a phenotype but most
likely they don't change the structure
of the protein
and even if they're in the non-coding
region we will also expect them to have
some potential impact especially if
they're found in the promoter region or
some splicing region of that gene
and then we will take a look at some
examples that can help us understand how
does this actually work in real life
situations
so what types of mutations are there
again we have the dna sequence
missense mutations nonsense mutations
and frame shift mutations and those are
the basic types so a missense mutation
is a change in one dna base pair that
results in the substitution of one amino
acid for another and the protein made by
a gene
nonsense mutation is a change in one dna
base pair that
prematurely signals the cell to stop
building a protein this type of mutation
results in a shortened protein that may
function improperly or not at all
frame shift mutation is an addition or
loss of dna basis that changes the genes
reading frame and the resulting protein
is used is usually non-functional
so now that we understand this genomic
variation
we can start thinking about how can we
identify such individual variants
or what other types of variants can we
expect to find
so if you imagine
and we'll talk about sequencing in just
a few more minutes if you imagine a
sequence that comes out from a sequencer
typically we refer that as to that as a
read that read can contain a single
position that has a change
if we align multiple reads to each other
many times we will find that one
position has multiple changes
and so then we want to ask the question
are these changes
consistent
what is the
majority of the changes what is the
smaller proportion of the changes and
then we try to categorize them and so
that categorization can lead us to
determine whether this is a single
nucleotide variant
a single nucleotide polymorphism
or are we seeing other
bigger rearrangements that we should be
paying attention to and those could
include copy number variations and
ultimately all of these could result in
a change in a phenotype
so
how does bioinformatics help us in this
kind of genomic characterization of
variance
well we will first need to understand
how sequencing works to appreciate the
need for computational analysis of
genomic data and then to actually
practically see what does this data look
like
so
what i'll do in the next few slides is
i'll talk about
sequencing technologies and how they
differ from each other and briefly jump
into an example of one of these
technologies
and then we'll talk about several
examples and i'll actually use just one
example today and that will be an
example from cancer
next generation sequencing as i already
mentioned has evolved dramatically over
the past couple of decades and
originally it started from a technique
that was very expensive and labor
intensive
and eventually now it is becoming more
and more automated as well as cheaper
and more accessible
and so as a result we actually have
several different categories of
sequencers
these are called short read sequencers
or long read sequencers those are the
dominant types of sequencing
technologies today
and these are all next generation
sequencing or the second generation
sequencing technologies
the first generation sequencing
technologies that were much more
expensive
are still used for a lot of validation
but primarily when we deal with this
kind of data we're going to be using
these next generation sequencing
sequencers the machines are called
sequencers
so here you can see aluminum machines um
i think you have the iron torin here as
well as oxford nanopore for long read
sequencers and pac bio or pacific
biosciences so the short
sequencing technologies are the cheapest
ones
the benefit of the short reads isn't
that they're short but that they can be
very inexpensive and they can be
generated in a massively parallel manner
with billions being generated in a
single run
so the cost
is lower and so when you need the cost
to be lower and the count of reads or
your
ability to cover a certain region with a
high number of reads is needed short
read technology makes the most sense
long reads on the other hand can resolve
regions of the genome that are
inaccessible to short reads due to
repeat sequences
and so if you have
multiple sequences that are exactly the
same you're going to run into a
challenge of mapping and an
alternative route is to generate longer
reads
so
the pacific biosciences
technology can generate reads that are
over 15 000 bases long
and some could be even over 100 000 long
at oxford nanopore technologies the
platform under the right conditions with
high quality dna can produce reads of up
to 1 million bases so these are very
very long reads and recently you might
have heard that these technologies have
been used to remap the human genome and
identify a lot of the
repeated sequences and actually
determine what is in them
now these types of sequencers
could also vary based on what is it that
we are feeding into the machine and that
is what's called library preparation so
we can either sequence everything by
just chopping up the dna
and putting it into the flow cell or we
could amplify specific regions and be
selective about what are we actually
trying to sequence
so
uh based on this
in when it comes to genomics there are
basically several approaches and this is
whole genome whole exome or targeted
sequencing when we talk about whole
genome sequences sequencing we're
typically expecting a fairly low
coverage the average is about five reads
in a position which means that we
will you know typically have if we're
again going back to those single
nucleotide variants right we're going to
be able to detect five reads that either
all have a change in the sequence or
only a proportion of them have that
change in the sequence so that doesn't
have a lot of data to work with per each
position but the number of
nucleotides is going to be huge so if
you think of the human genome which is
about 3.2 billion nucleotides that is
going to give you 3.2
uh 3.2
sorry
billion uh positions
with five reads that you can
kind of measure what types of variants
are you finding
the typical approach though is going to
be whole exome sequencing so whole exome
sequencing means that we're only
identifying regions that are known to
contain protein coating
areas and those are exons right so as we
will see in a few minutes those are not
the full sequence of the reeds but only
exons and not the introns now sometimes
especially in the situations where you
want a very high confidence variant
calling
you would like to sequence only specific
genes for example if i'm looking at
variants that i know of that are
clinically relevant and i don't care
about anything else that is in the
genome i might want to only target
specific genes and that again is called
amplicon sequences sequencing that is
focused on just an individual gene or
maybe several genes or a gene panel
now how does sequencing actually work
the way it works as i mentioned is that
genomic dna is first shattered or cut up
into pieces
then those pieces are put into a library
uh sorry there are adapters that are
attached to those reeds and then it's
put into a flow cell in within the flow
cell there's a process called bridge pcr
amplification and so then all of this
genomic material is fed into the
sequencer and the sequencer is actually
trying to determine for each position
of that read what is that nucleotide so
as a result you have this digital output
and that digital output is stored in
several different file formats
these file formats that we're going to
be dealing with a lot are fastq
fasta and gtf fast q files contain the
individual read sequences with the
quality associated with each position
faster files typically contain just the
full sequence this could be the
reference sequence or even sometimes
individual reads or maybe portions like
uh
genes or something could be contained in
a faster file and then another file that
is often used is a reference file the
annotation file and that could be the
gtf or the gff file
so
these three are going to be used
a lot in our work with dna sequences and
you really need to understand how these
files are organized so here you can see
an example of a fasta file the fasta
file as you can see has a name
so right here on the top this name could
mean the specific gene the specific
chromosome or the full organism name
sometimes it will have the full
description of that
sequence
and then inside it will typically have
either a nucleotide or amino acid
sequence without any breaks or organized
in specific links like this one is
organized in specific links
a fastq file
contains information about sequencing
quality and so here you can see that for
each read like this is a single read it
will contain the sequence of that read
but also for each position it will
contain the information about the
sequencing quality and based on this
quality we can for example eliminate low
quality reads or reads that are of
inconsistent links and we'll take a look
at that today as well
so here's an individual read that as you
can see contains two pieces of
information it's the same name
one contains the sequence one contains
the quality information
how do we analyze this kind of data what
we will use throughout this platform
throughout this program is a platform
called the t bioinfo platform this
platform is going to link the concepts
that we
use for each step of the analysis
with the outputs that we're going to
perform downstream analysis with
and this platform combines many
different types of analyses that we will
use throughout this program and those
will include
alignment of reads to identify specific
variants in positions according to their
position on the reference dna
they deal with variant calling how to
distinguish between
random changes that are a result of
maybe some
you know changes that happen because of
sequencing errors from actual variants
and categorize them as well as other
downstream methods of analysis like
phylogenetic analysis mutability
analysis and others
so let's go back to the learn portal
and i will show you how you will be able
to get into that
platform and and get started with
genomic data analysis but before i do
please let me know if you have any
questions about what we covered so far
uh you can just type in your question in
the chat and when we have a little break
i'll be able to answer any of those
questions
so again this is the program page where
you're registered and then once you are
registered you should have created a
profile like for hana already mentioned
and
within that profile you will be able to
access different courses so for example
the first course
that we are talking about is genomics
so this course will describe everything
that i talked about today in greater
detail and much slower so if you want to
repeat that you can go ahead and do that
you need to be able to access all of the
lessons that are here and you will
notice that some of the lessons have a
yellow star next to them
so the first few lessons are going to be
free anyone can take them and then
as you uh
go into more depth you will need to have
a subscription so that subscription is
what is provided with this program
and thank you sanjay for the question
does the pipeline also include the
suggested software and programs yes so
based on the pipeline you will be able
to download and install your own
software if you want to rebuild the
pipeline on your own
so
what we'll do today is we will cover
several of these examples just to kind
of understand what are these different
file formats what do they look like and
how do we deal with them
and so as i mentioned and by the way
does everyone have access can you please
put in the chat if you have access to
this course and you can access what i'm
seeing on the screen again i'm pasting
the link
in the chat
so please let me know in the chat if
you're able to access this course and
see what i see
here on the screen
yes excellent thank you
okay so we'll skip the first lesson you
can go through that on your own if you
want to review the basics let's open
working with
dna sequences in r
okay so don't worry we're not actually
going to install r we're just going to
understand the very basics of what's in
a fasta sequence what does the dna
sequence look like and what can we do
with it
so as you can see right here we have a
brief introduction and our by the way is
a very useful
coding environment that you can set up
on your own system or you can run in the
cloud in today's session we'll do a very
short example it's going to be very
simple you don't have to know any coding
but as you go through the different uh
lessons you'll learn more and more about
what you could do
once you learn about different packages
that are included with r
the basic idea in r is that you create
an object and that object in this case
is going to contain the sequence and can
also have a name so for example
string1
you can put any string and you use
quotation marks to identify what is a
string as opposed to what you expect to
be an object or a function
in string two i now have another string
and that string happens to be a dna
sequence so to work with dna sequences i
don't need any specialized tools if i'm
just trying to load them view them or
understand how many characters do they
have
sometimes we want to do very simple
things like convert dna sequences to rna
sequences
so here
we just do a simple substitution we
substitute one type of a character
t for another type of character you
sometimes
we want to be able to use a library and
a library contains a lot of
functionality that we don't have to
write we don't have to figure out how it
works it just works
and all we need to do is call a function
with the right kind of parameters that
will produce the result that we want
now let's take a look at one of the most
commonly
performed tasks for genomic data which
is alignment
what is a language alignment is
essentially taking one string of
sequences
and trying to understand how similar is
it to another string
for example because it has
many characters
i don't know how many of the characters
are an exact match how many were
inserted how many were deleted or how
many were substituted so i would like to
understand and to do that i don't need
to think about manually aligning the
sequence i can use again a library in
this case we're going to use two
libraries one called decipher and one
called biostrings to both perform
alignment and visualize the results
now if you perform this and first we're
going to read about it then we're going
to actually do it together
as you can see the result is going to
introduce additional characters that are
representative of gaps
so
this sequence is longer
this sequence is shorter so if i want to
align them to each other i need to add
some additional characters that are gaps
not only that i will also see that if i
introduce a certain number of changes i
can assign a score to those changes
based on how many changes i have
i will have different number of
different
scores as a result for example here we
have one two three four
missing
nucleotides in the first sequence
so my score ended up being 102.68
in the second example i have a much
longer sequence in the first
pattern right in the first sequence that
i have and then this is the second
sequence i'm aligning and my score is
minus 206. so this gives you some
intuition into what the score actually
represents it just tells you the quality
of alignment
now in addition to that we will see how
this kind of simple alignment
is useful in several different examples
so now when i click on next so again i'm
on step number three
let's perform this we can do this
actually right in the browser
so all i need to do is i need to run
this code
so by clicking on the run button
i am loading the libraries
then i'm assigning
different sequences to two objects
and then i am aligning those objects and
here what's important for the score to
understand the score i'm using the first
one and then the second one
okay
after i click on run it prints what the
alignment ends up being and so here in
the console i can see the alignment
result and the alignment result
adds these additional characters at the
end and provides me with a score
okay yes you can definitely practice on
our studio the reason why we're doing
this in the browser is because the
browser has the answers right
so as you are getting started you want
to be able to replicate exactly what is
expected
once it works and you understand the
syntax you can take it onto your own
environment and now work with that but
before you jump into that let's make
sure that you can get exactly what we
have here
which also includes all of the libraries
and dependencies that have to be
installed and to work exactly the same
for everybody who's using that so that's
why we're using the browser
okay so now
let's try to see
what happens if we change these
sequences okay so if you scroll here to
the end you can see that the second
result is longer
let's scroll through over here
again it is longer right
are there any packages so the packages
that we are using uh sanjay is right
here the library deciphering biostrings
contains multiple functions
so to install these on your own system
you would have to install
this library and this library and you
can do that in our studio
so i'll just show you in our studio you
will go to tools and you will say
install packages and here under install
packages you would have to install those
packages but i'm not going to spend a
lot of time on this now because i'm
trying to cover a lot in our first
session
and after this you will have plenty of
times time to set up everything on your
own computer that's why we want to use
the browser
okay
so here the second exercise again all
you need to do is just run it
and the objective here is to compare the
scores right you can see the score here
is 102.
here the score is only 55
right
so the difference
is noticeable right it's half
now you have an assignment and i'll give
you just a couple of minutes here
to perform this assignment now that you
understand how this code works and you
understand that we're trying to align
two sequences to each other
the assignment is to align you can see
here the exact same sequence to each
other
right so here
we aligned dnaseq1 to dnaseq2 then we
changed a little bit the second sequence
and we again perform the same thing
now let's try to see if you can figure
out how to align the exact same sequence
dna seq 2
to each other to to itself sorry
okay so please try to do this and let me
know when you have the result
uh
okay
so if you don't know yet what are you
supposed to do and how to do this let's
do it together what i will do is i will
take a look at my first example right
always if you ask anyone who's doing
analysis they always look at somebody
else's examples so let's just take a
look at this example right here
the key line is line number 10.
you can see that the alignment is
performed in this line number 10.
so i go to line number 10 and i see what
is missing right because if i run this
it is going to give me an error
so it says air running code so let's
clear this
and let us write what we have here so i
can just copy this pairwise alignment
dna c1 dnac2
paste it over here
but it said the assignment is instead of
doing it dnac2
i need to change dnac2 to dnac1 to dnac2
let's try to run this
excellent so success running code and
answer is correct right in sanjay and
raphael you were asking how to run this
on your computer right obviously this
isn't something that we could you could
have known that you've run correctly
because our system allows us to actually
check on the back end that this is done
exactly the same okay so what is the
score
the score that we got is 152.59
so let's compare this course
here we have one zero two
here we have 55 and here we have 152.
let me ask you a question what do you
think happens to the score as sequences
become more and more similar to each
other does the score increase or
decrease
exactly so raphael correctly said and
comment the score will increase right so
we can see that the sequences are
exactly the same the score is higher and
when we introduce more and more changes
it is going to be different
why do you think it is different so as
you can see
you probably just copied this and pasted
it here but the assignment is
right read this please
alignment between the exact same
sequence okay so if you just take this
which is dna seq 1 and dna c2
you're going to get a result
right but the result is going to be just
like here 55.4
55.4 right and the answer is incorrect
so what you need to do is you need to
change this to 2.
does that make sense uh sanjay
excellent okay
so
very quickly we understood how to work
with dna we know what we're looking for
we know how to evaluate it we can align
multiple sequences to each other
as you go through the material you will
find more and more advanced
steps that you need to take and that
will give you a good sense of what
people do when they use bioinformatics
now
as you remember this individual sequence
is only one read
so let's take a look at how does this
data actually look like when we have
actual sequencing raw data
to do that we will go to the platform
so the platform
is called the t bioinfo platform you
also have a lot of introductory material
on the platform and what we will do is
we will perform
alignment of many many different short
sequences to the reference genome
okay so please let me know once you
reach this platform
and log in how do you know that you're
logged in you hover over this area right
here and you should see your email
address right here
so if
and please confirm that you can log in
because sometimes people
don't receive the email and password
uh typically your email and password
from the learn portal should work here
as well
but maybe you didn't get it or you don't
remember it or something so please do
let me know that you can log in
okay does anyone
have access to this
platform
okay so
you don't have it so if you go here
right uh
you can just log in so i'll log out
okay you go to login
and you use the exact same password that
you have on your learn portal do you
have that information
okay sanjay it looks like you do have an
account okay
perfect so what we want to do today is
going to be a demo it's not going to be
an actual analysis an actual analysis
will take some time but in this case
we're going to go through a very brief
example
right here you can find all kinds of
sections related to next generation
sequencing data
what we want to do is we want to go to
mutation variant parallel analysis of
mutation variant data
and click right here on the drop down
okay
our peta or peta could you please uh
put your email address so we can uh take
note of it for hana if you could maybe
take note um so we can share that with
sonalika and by our next session or
hopefully even before that
everybody should have access so you
should be able to get your password
all right excellent so looks like you're
okay so it looks like you're at lsu so
please email
for hana or
so
farhan i don't know if you can put your
email address here but also you can
email support
at pine.bio
and you should get your account
information there
okay so what we want to do
is we want to go to this section
mutation variant parallel analysis of
mutation variant data
okay
uh you click on the drop down right here
and you want to go to this first demo so
again this is going to be a demo variant
calling cell lines
once you're in you'll see that each
button here represents an algorithm or a
script just like what we did there in r
that's a script i can make it into a
standalone script
provided with some inputs and it's going
to run every time i call it so here i
have many different scripts and my goal
is to piece them together into a series
of scripts that we will call pipeline
these pipelines can contain from two
to maybe 20 or even 50 different scripts
combined together and they will provide
us with an output that is more easy to
work with than the individual
intermediate outputs that we could
produce just running those scripts
so to begin you have to click on start
and every time you will have a pop-up
that has some explanation of what the
script does or what we are intending to
do in this specific pipeline
then click on ok
and you will have two options
highlighted these are the two options
that you have to select next
either you would like to clean your data
or you would like to align your data to
the reference genome which is called
mapping so this is mapping of those
reads to the right position on the
reference genome
let's click on bow tie two
so bow tie two is an algorithm that is
used
it relies on the burrows wheeler
transform which is a method of
transforming strings that is used in
many different applications including
search when you do a search and you want
to find a specific word in your document
this is also an efficient way to search
for that word so when you work with
strings these algorithms are
multi-purpose algorithms and in this
case this particular bwt
was used in bow tie
and if you want to know more about this
algorithm you can just go to this
publication right here
once you click on bow tie two you then
want to add this module for
visualization so what we'll use is again
a standalone
set of functionality called jbrowse
which is a package that is used to
visualize the genome and you can find it
being used in many different parts of
the internet if you've ever looked on
reference genomes and you've kind of
seen some compilations of data
likely they have used jbrowse to
visualize that
so now we're going to click on end and
we have ourselves a pipeline this
pipeline has four different steps
we loaded the data and start we then map
the data to the reference genome and
then we want to visualize the individual
reads that have been mapped on the
genome position
and then we finished our pipeline
okay so
if you
completed this exactly like i did you
should have gotten this link right here
that says visualization
did anyone
complete this pipeline and get the link
for visualization or should we try to do
this again
all right perfect
so rafael got it did anyone else
all right excellent so let's click on
visualization and let's see what comes
up
yes and i will go back really quickly
just to repeat everything from the
beginning so we're on areas of analysis
here
you can see that we have mutation
variant parallel analysis of mutation
variant data and i click on this drop
down
okay so raphael will get to the
visualization in just a second
then you click on this first demo demo
variant calling cell lines
once you get here you click on start
bow tie two
visualization
end
okay and now you should have a link that
says visualization
now initially when you just click on
visualization
you might see
something like this there's nothing
there
okay everything is empty
you can do two things
first of all this is
a full chromosome right so right here
you have a drop down
that has different chromosomes
right here you have the exact position
on the chromosome now i don't
just know the position for every gene
so what's a better way to do this is to
search for a gene for example a gene
that i know
is braca
one
so bracha one right here
is a gene on chromosome 17 so i can
click on go
and now we found
this gene right so you can see that
bracket gene actually has
many different transcripts
and what you can see is that the pink
area is the exon
and the black line are the introns
so it consists of many different exons
some of them are very short some of them
are longer and a lot of introns
and that is your genome gene so this
right here is the gtf file the genome
annotation file that's right here genome
genes
here you also have the reference
sequence the reference sequence is the
actual genome so if you zoom in
and you want to see
the sequence
this is the sequence right here
so i have to zoom in a lot and then you
will see your sequence as well as those
codons that we were talking about right
and if you want you can actually move
this to the top
okay so now that we have this let's zoom
back out we don't actually want to see
the reference sequence right now it
doesn't make sense for us to look at
that close of a zoom in we want to see
our exons and we want to see what the
gene looks like
okay so the chromosomes are right here
the position of the chromosome is right
here this is the annotation all of this
has nothing to do with the data that we
uploaded
what do you think the data that we
upload looks like
well that data has
individual reads right so right here you
can see that we actually uploaded two
data sets or two files
these are two fast queue files
and they are represented by the aligned
file so now the fast queue has turned
into a bam file and if you click on one
of them just let's click on the first
one called alignment
you can see down below it says too much
data to show zoom in to see detail
so let's zoom in a little bit
let's scroll down
and now you should be able to see the
individual reads
okay so in fact if you click on them
you will see all that information that
we saw in the fastq file
this is the actual read
and this is the sequence and its quality
you can also see
how long is this read so
if you found a read
tell me how long it is
if you
looked
if you were able to open it you should
be able to see
in this information of an individual
read how long is the read
okay or you can see it on my screen
so how long is this read that i'm
looking at
where did i i clicked on one of the
reads
so these are these little yep exactly
thank you
or peta so if you click on one of these
this window will pop up
and you will see
the read length right and so that
previous one was 101 this one is 108 so
you can see that the read lengths are
actually a little bit different
but they are all around 100
nucleotides long
okay 108 yeah so it really depends on
which read you selected and it doesn't
matter which one right this is just to
show you that these individual reads
are right here and those are the
sequences just like we were aligning
those two sequences to each other that's
what happened here but with many
different sequences
now this information as you can see is
cut off so we actually don't see the
full information that we have so instead
of looking at this
at the level of alignment we can also
select coverage and snip
okay so if you scroll down
right here
you can see that not all regions
are covered per or equally right
so
since this is kind of shorter than the
other one i'm again going to move it up
okay and and now i have a question for
you is this whole genome sequencing
whole exome sequencing or amplicon
sequencing what do you think
amplicon so our peta is saying amplicon
any other ideas
our pita
seems like egg zone uh exome sanjay is
saying so arpita why do you think this
is
exome and sanjay or komei why do you
think this is
uh egg zone or amplicon yeah why do you
think what you're saying
okay the answer is
that
it's not full genome
right okay so repeat is saying sequence
stretches are short only coding area
seems to have the reads that's right so
if you look where this is it is only the
coding region right so this matches
exactly this uh red or pink little
section as well as all of these
abundances so the majority of the reads
actually just map here
how do i know that this is not just
amplicon the answer would be if i can
find another gene right so first of all
i can of course zoom out and i can see
that multiple genes have coverage so
this will take a little bit to load but
you will see that multiple genes have
coverage but also i can go to another
gene let me just go to another gene for
example tp53 the p53 gene
go to this one
go
right and here again i see that the
abundance is just around the exons right
so because i can see that the abundance
in multiple locations are just above
exons i see i can conclude that this is
whole exome sequencing data
apart from this you can see that this
section is supposed to show me snips
and those snips are the actual variants
right the changes in the sequences that
we will find that are associated with
some phenotype and in this particular
case we don't see
any changes
in this sequence but if we
keep scrolling eventually we will find
them right
so
we're
at the end of our session so let me
briefly conclude
what we saw today was how to
analyze next generation sequencing data
and find genomic variation this genomic
variation is going to be the basis of a
lot of what we do throughout this
program
we're going to look at multiple sequence
alignment and alignment to the reference
genome we're going to understand the
relationship between nucleotide
sequences and amino acid sequences and
we're going to use a variety of tools
that first we need to understand the
logical application of these tools
how can we build multiple types of
pipelines to get what we want from the
type of data that we have
this will include calling somatic
mutations like in cancer it will be
performing genome-wide association
studies and identifying what particular
positions on the genome can be
associated with a phenotype
we're also going to look at how
different types of changes have an
impact on the structure of that
particular protein
and all of this will be provided to you
as a series of practical steps that you
can perform independently over the
course of the next three months
so raphael can you download the pipeline
file from tbio and use in rstudio
most of these methods are not written in
r
you can perform some of the same in r
but not all of it so you can't just
download and do it in rstudio some of
the methods that we will use you can and
so when we get to those i will
specifically point those out
now you will have multiple examples
that
show how this type of analysis is used
for
different types of applications so in
the same course that we were the
synchronous course
you will go from the very introductory
material that we looked at today
two other types of analysis techniques
multiple sequence alignment you will
find exercises that you should be able
to do in r as well
analysis of mutability differential
mutation analysis copy number variation
and others
and so as you go through this course
hopefully you will be able to appreciate
the value that is found in genomic
sequencing data and some of the baseline
experiments that you can analyze data
from to understand the differences
between
mutations uh variance differences in
copy number variation etc
can we perform our own set of
experiments on these platforms and use
the pipeline yes you can and that was
the point of that project that we
discussed
when farhana was showing you the profile
so this is an advanced program in the
sense that it will provide you with
skills that you can directly apply into
a data set
do we have courses on methylation
analysis yes so whole genome bisulfide
sequencing is a part of epigenomics so
you will find that in a course called
epigenomics
okay so if you have any other questions
please feel free to reach out to us for
hana is at lsu you can meet with her we
want to know what questions what
concerns what issues you are facing so
that we can prepare for our next q a
session that is going to be um february
uh when february
the key organization the first one is
february 21st
and the second one is march 18.
okay
perfect so those are the dates uh any
questions that you have uh please make
sure to let us know about them uh if you
have any questions about you know what
else is covered or what else are we
going to be able to do you can go back
to the syllabus and refer to the
different sections that we have
we will be sending you
videos recorded videos that you can
watch that seek to connect the different
aspects of what is found online and if
you have any questions during the q a
session we will be able to address those
all right and excellent raphael i'm
excited to see that you're enjoying it
so hopefully everyone
is going to benefit from this as well
finally my personal email address is
ilia pine.bio
i can reply
if you have any technical issues and if
you have any technical issues about any
of the assignments you can also write to
support at pine.bio and get any
questions from our support team answered
right away
thank you again for joining today we're
going to be excited to see your progress
and
looking forward to
the next few months together
thank you everyone sorry
thank you
you